يا
ايها
المختار من خير
الوراء
خلقا
وخلقا بالك
مال
توحدا
اخوه الانشاد عن ابيهم يكونوا فرقه بدات
من سوريا وطافت بلاد العالم تمتع جمهورها
بطاقه روحانيه عاليه ضيوف اليوم الاخوه
ابو شعر
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
كلكم اخوات هل ده كان مفتاح من مفاتيح
نجاحكم وانتشاركم
باخيك ان تميز فرقه الاخوه بكلمه الاخوه
ابو شعب يعني يوم فلان من الاخوه عيان
تعبان فيقوم بدال الاربعه التانيين ويقوم
الخمسه
[موسيقى]
بما انك اصغر واحد في الفريق هل حبيت
الانشاد قسوه بوالدك ولا باخواتك الكبار
على مجتمع ابي بينشد اخواتي الكبار كلهم
بينشدوا امي كانت تنشد بالبيت طبعا وكان
عندي اندفاع قوي فكان في فرق بالسن كبير
بيني وبين اخواتي هم كان فرقه نظاميه ست
سنوات فكان شكلي امام الناس صعب على
الستيج من اشياء الطرف انها ذكرتها
انا لما بدات مع الاخوه ابو شعر جلست على
الكرسي انا واخي انس على كرسي واحد ههه
جلست على كرسي بمفرده بدون ميكروفون بعدها
جلست لكن بدون سلك
بعد المرحله الاخرى جلست بمايكروفون وصلت
بس السلك ممدود ومرمي بالارض قدام الميكسر
مانو محطوط بالمكسر ههه
لا خلاص نحط السلك وبدات انشد وبدات اخد
فرصتي بالفرقه يعني بما انك شاركت
هل بتحب اكثر الانسجام وسط اخواتك ولا
فكره الاختلاف وسط فرقه كل واحد فيهم من
المدرسه مختلفه كمؤدي انا بنسجم مع اخوتي
صراحه هلا انا حاتكلم انا كاخوه
واحقاقا للحق اخواتي عندهم شيء مانو موجود
عند غيرهم او قليل لتلاقي عند غيرهم في
عندهم صدق بالجلوس على المسرح في عندهم
صدق لما بقولوا الكلمه وما بعرف لو انت
سمعتي هلا نحن اللي بيقولوا لعقه من العسل
تغني عن محاضره عن العسل اما بالاستماع
لما بجلس انا بمكان فيه فرقه بحب اسمع
الفكره الثانيه يكون كل واحد بالمدرسه انا
ما بممل
على النبي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات